und das jetzt hier ist eine
ameisenstraße das ist kein verrücktes
naturschauspiel das hier sind autos das
sind wohnwagen das sind pick ups dicht
an die ganz eng gedrängt das hier ist
ein 15 kilometer langer stau einmal quer
durch die wüste von nevada
das sind bilder nach dem burning man das
schrägste festival der welt ein mix aus
mad max woodstock und star trek quasi
80.000 aus aller welt kommen da jedes
jahr in die wüste von nevada um tag und
nacht wirklich party zu machen und jetzt
stehen sie nach neun tagen frei einen
ganzen tag lang im stau acht bis zwölf
stunden warten bei 40 grad in der wüste
[Musik]
mega stau nacht xxl festival im us
bundesstaat nevada herrschen nachdem
burning man festival apokalyptische
zustände
in der wüste von nevada stellt
festivalbesucher acht stunden im stau
das burning man festival ist eine
mischung aus mad max und woodstock und
wurde 1986 von einer gruppe von
künstlern ins leben gerufen zwei jahre
musste das event wegen corona pausieren
mit dem xxl festival feierten 80.000
techno-fans künstler und pyrotechniker
in der temporären stadt lag rock city
ganze neun tage
aufgrund der vielen gäste standen einige
festivalbesucher ganze acht stunden im
stau bevor sie das gelände verlassen
konnten doch den fans machte die lange
wartezeit nichts aus immerhin konnten
sie jetzt ihren rausch ausschlafen
[Musik]